[Music]
keisha
is in wichita kansas hi keisha how are
you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can john and i help
well um i don't honestly i'm not sure
that i'm asking the right question but
i i'm struggling with feeling like
if i approach my mother-in-law i
disrespect my husband
because my mother-in-law
talks negatively about me to family and
friends when she is upset
and honestly i'm not sure why
it started shortly after we
became married we've been married almost
six years have two great children
um and it's just kind of getting worse
so i don't
i know i can't control other people but
i want to
support and respect my husband in every
which way because
um he leads a wonderful family
and so give me an example
when she gets upset give me an example
of that
uh so the most recent was she was in a
disagreement with
her other son and um
she then called him disrespectful
and isn't sure where he learned that and
said that i must be rubbing off on him
as well
um did he immediately tell his mom
do not disrespect my wife no that was
her son her brother
that was that that was my brother-in-law
um but
he shared he shared that with my husband
and yes
my my husband immediately
talked to her and said don't ever do
this again
okay um you know but but this is it's
not the first time and i know it's not
going to be the last time
so how is her what's her reaction when
her son what do we do
when her son calls her on the carpet
your husband
and says hey mom you can't talk about my
wife like that come on
what's your problem stop it what did she
say
right there's no apologies there's
blaming
of either him or i
um she's never wrong with it
okay so there's really there's really
two choices you got um
right choice number one is let your
husband know hey i i'm feeling this
burning in my soul i want to sit down
with her and just ask
i'd love to make peace with the
grandparents of my kid
the grandmother of my kids right you'd
have to understand
and you make peace with the fact that
peace may never come
and at the end of the day you've got to
unhit yourself from this woman who's
just
choosing to bring poison into your life
and i know that sounds trite and silly
and how am i supposed to do that
at the end of the day you're gonna have
to make a decision that old lady can
just say whatever she's gonna say
but i'm gonna love my kids i'm a good
wife i'm a good friend i'm a good
neighbor
um i got a great husband and i'm going
to go about my life i'm not going to let
her dictate my world
right i i am i'm personally a fan of
face-to-face conversations but i've had
to make peace over the years with the
fact that some people
a don't want to have them with me or b
they have no interest in any sort of
reconciliation because like you said
they're narcissistic
never wrong yeah they're never wrong
but i always want to know i went down
swinging on that one yeah you gave it
every shot so
it might be that that you you and your
husband and uh
your father-in-law and mother-in-law go
to dinner one night you all buy
and just say um you know i'm not trying
to correct you
at all i just want to tell you that we
love you we respect you
and i don't want anything but good
things between us
and i and i won't be ever saying
anything bad about you behind your back
ever right you can count on me to cut to
take your back
i'll always take your side behind your
back
and if if i ever have any issue with you
um either your son or i will discuss it
with you we will not discuss it with
other people
and we just want you to know that we
love you and respect you and and
gosh if you could do that for us that
would be the greatest gift in the world
but even if you don't
we love you we respect you and you're
the grandparents of our kids
and it just seems like it just shames
the crud out of it it's the old bible
verse about heaping coles right yeah
if you can write a letter just tell her
i'm glad you're the grandmother of my
kids i love you
and i want you to respect you and um
like i love
that i hope that you'll do the same for
me if you ever have any challenge with
me please give me a shout
but here's the thing some people make a
decision to be test pilot for a broom
factory
and this woman is she she's like a
second degree lieutenant
test pilot for the broom factory that's
what she is
and so if she just decides i'm gonna be
a [ __ ]
the rest of my life and you're attached
to her through her son
you just have that attachment and you
just go that's the crazy one over there
in the corner look at her
check out the pointed hat you know i
mean so that's just you know you just
have to kind of put that in your head
and kind of grin and go on because every
family's got some right
right that's that is that is very true
it's hard but that that's where you said
it you said it early in the conversation
you said it
you said i can't control her
so i mean you've intellectually got that
part but the problem put it down the
next trip is
to emotionally get that part there you
go i can't control it
because here's what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what it is
you're doing
and you're not doing anything you're not
doing anything there's something way
back in her childhood
that just is in her interaction with her
husband or something
who knows i don't know somewhere along
the line hurting people hurt people
and usually these situations are real
frustrating for me because we got a
husband
who won't step up to his mom and that's
not the case here you got a man
i love your husband i love your husband
it's awesome
and he likes you too yeah he's good
he's you know because usually i i get
this wife i get this call and i'm
dealing with a wuss
and a husband he will stand up to his
little mommy right you know
and this guy's a stud and he wasn't mean
to her he just called her out
yeah but in her world anybody in in her
little narcissistic world anybody who
calls her out is called mean yeah
yours is so mean so here's here's the
messy part of this
you have a fantasy in your head about
christmas and thanksgiving
that has these perfect grandparents that
welcome your kids and they run out of
the car and they hug you
and you can call her about challenges
with your kid
this doesn't exist you're just gonna
have the halloween character show up
yeah sure thanksgiving
you gotta let the fantasy go and i hate
that for you
but it's most families it's most famous
it is it is but i
we all have the fantasy and it's in it's
like freaking leave it
to beaver did this to this culture we
all think june cleaver's out there
somewhere
and she's i don't know where she went
i think she died about a generation ago
but
[Music]
but we've got the little white picket
fence and the little functional family
and most most families put the fun and
dysfunction i'm just saying